does demi lovato have a baby on the way
not so fast
the singer hit up Instagram on Wednesday
posting this mirror selfie cradling what
appears to be a baby bump giving her
fans a minor heart attack well until
they read the caption which said quote
real or fake hashtag Will and Grace
hashtag meet Jenny the 27 year old took
the pic and this video from the set of
Will & Grace where she's currently
filming a reoccurring role I'm excited
her co-star Sean Hayes slid into the
comment section writing you look so dang
cute in polka-dots thank you
her manager Scooter Braun also weighed
in writing Mazel Tov then when youtuber
Nikita Dragan commented me after
Chipotle Demi responded looks like we
need another Taco Tuesday Demi also
shared this tweet from a fan who wrote
Demi is pregnant with d7 referencing her
highly anticipated seventh studio album
Demi's response this is true very soon
as all I can really say so fingers
crossed that it's sooner than you think
and guys she is not lying on Wednesday
scooter shared this sneak peek at Demi
in the studio and Emmy playing music yes
but back to Demi and that baby bump the
singer recently made her new
relationship with LA based model Austin
Wilson insta official posting this pic
with the caption my heart so naturally
some fans were quick to jump to
conclusions about the pic at first
glance one person wrote you need a
part-time full-time nanny I can start
right now
I'll read books to your bump well
another tagged Demi's new man in their
comment reading damn bruh you didn't
waste any time gotta love the Internet
the 27 year old has been filming her
role as Jenny for several weeks and has
given fans
behind-the-scenes on Instagram so much
fun
the casting news was originally
announced on the Today Show back in
August and this morning we can
exclusively reveal that Demi's gonna be
joining the cast of a Will & Grace here
on NBC playing the role of Jenny a quote
tough guarded woman who comes into wills
life in an unexpected way shortly after
that demi confirmed the news herself
posting this photo on set and the show
star Debra Messing appears to be all
about Debbie's reoccurring cameo she
shared this selfie with Demi writing
I've got a crush she was super cool
super sweet on the current season of the
NBC reboot will played by Eric McCormack
is looking for a surrogate so Demi I
mean Jenny just might be that person of
course you can count on ET to fill you
in on all the deeds when Debbie's
episode finally airs so make sure to
keep it locked right here I'm Hallie
Stephens see you next time
[Music]